I like drawing a curveball at the
beginning first let me start with
congrats on the movie I thought you did
such a great job with this
um but I'm curious if someone has never
seen anything you've acted in or
directed before uh what is the first
thing you'd like them watching and why
uh this film because I think it's the
best thing I've made
um I think you know I made Garden State
which I which I'm very proud of but I
made it at 25 years old I was very young
and green and and I I certainly didn't
think anyone was going to see the movie
beyond my parents and the temple choir
um I I went on to I have such a
reverberation that I I I I that it comes
up every day in my life to this day
but I feel like through through
directing all the things I've directed
since and
um especially of late with with lasso
and and shrinking and and the TV stuff
I've done and uh this show called solos
I did on Amazon that I'm I'm really
proud of I feel like I I I I I I got
better I learned a lot and um and I
think this is um the thing I'm most
proud of for sure do you think that
having Morgan Freeman narration in the
movie is like entering a cheat code in a
video game
that's funny
um
yes and no I mean if he's just saying
I mean who cares it's just a
beautiful voice saying I I
hoped that it's the magic of good
writing with that voice
um but I will tell you that he one day
lost a bet to me on when we were making
going in style and and uh when he lost
the bet uh my outgoing voicemail message
was his voice uh saying to leave a
message
where's all that's amazing and second of
all I think the narration in this movie
is very appropriate totally works
um when you are trying to depict
Addiction on screen in a movie or on a
show if you don't get it right it's like
touching the third rail of course and so
how nervous were you to try to take on
this kind of material because it really
if it doesn't work it's you know it's
all over there was no way I was gonna
let that happen I mean from day one I
was calling and texting with friends who
are very involved in in recovery and AAA
and n a and I know people of course and
have been the meanings to support people
but I I I was never gonna let that
happen um I put a lot of guard rails in
place
um I gave the script to people who are
very active in recovery I consulted with
a man who runs a recovery center and
then when we got into production we we
were put in touch with a woman who not
only overcame her own opioid addiction
but uh is is someone who counts uh young
women
and lots of people so she was on set for
every single scene anything related to
recovery and she was sitting by the
monitor next to me and I was like would
that poster actually be there and she's
like yeah yeah that looks good I'm
always curious about the editing process
because that's where it all comes
together so how did the film change in
the editing room perhaps in ways you
didn't expect well you know I agree with
you and I have to credit Dan shawk my
fantastic editor you you know I always
think of editing a a a a movie like
you've gone out in production is like a
scavenger hunt you're collecting as much
as you possibly can in 26 days and then
you get back to the edit suite and
you're like well what did we get and
usually you've gotten something that's
in my case usually two hours and 45
minutes long and you have to make these
tough choices what is the two-hour movie
in this two and a half 45 minute cut and
it's very hard you have to make choices
that always hurt
um and um but you have to because you're
you're really carving out what's the
best movie
within the clay that you've you've
you've amassed
um so there's stuff that ends up on The
Cutting Room floor that that's tough
sometimes but I think it's for the
greater good you obviously Florence cuts
her hair in the movie and you obviously
have to get that in one take I don't
know how you you know you do it more
than once so I'm curious how stressed
were you trying to make sure you were
going to be able to photograph it and
get it all without missing a beat I was
so nervous and then cutting her hair was
her her choice you know Florence was
really involved in the development of
the script and and she said I think it
would be really powerful after the
prologue when we find her if she's if
she's cutting her hair off and I said
that's like a production nightmare it's
genius it would be so cool but we don't
want to deal with Wigs Wigs look
horrible and we're not gonna how would
we even schedule that out of order and
she just kept saying you'll figure it
out you'll figure it out and I was like
Florence I spoke to the aeds I spoke to
the producers it's just not scheduleable
and she's like you'll figure it out and
she I was glad that she pushed us
um and because we did figure it out
because she kept pushing us and we
figured out a way to do it with no wigs
and um
and um and and so yeah it's really scary
because she's gonna cut Lop off her hair
live on one on camera and you only get
one take to get it right I want to make
sure I'm pronouncing this right Mario
Morrow Mauro Mauro okay right
um he obviously is a very talented
cinematographer and and you have some
very cool shots in the movie I'm just
curious talk a little bit about
collaborating with him on on the film
and what he brought to it that uh only
he could bring he's just incredible and
he you know I loved him when a lot he
shot some beautiful Antoine Fuqua movies
I thought training day is just a
beautiful movie
um uh um
um what's the Jake Gyllenhaal boxing
movie that's incredibly uh it's not
stronger is it no that's a different
that's David Gordon green it's um
uh Southpaw thank you
um Southpaw I just thought was stunning
and then he went on and he's done
enormous movies like he's got an Oscar
for it the first Avatar and he just did
the last Spider-Man but we had actually
made a short film together
um for Adobe and Florence was the star
with Alicia Silverstone so we got a
chance to work together and I was like
because I was nervous can a guy who's
made
these giant movies come and do small
scale still and he did and he was
incredible we made a beautiful short
film so then I uh I he was he was the
person I wanted to shoot this movie and
we just really hit it off I was nervous
because he was coming from Spider-Man
and I was like are you gonna be able to
shoot this movie in 26 days like you've
seen the schedule right and I just love
how how he adapted he said okay these
are my tools this is the size crew I
have this is the schedule and he made it
work and we uh he's just he's magical
and I think the movie's really really
beautiful because of him I gotta go but
just real fast who kept the train set
I wanted to keep the train set no one
had a spot for it but it was completely
bespoke and made for us by these uh
amazing uh guys who it is their hobby we
commissioned it from them and um and it
really was a a mock-up and to of the
town of South Orange New Jersey it was
gorgeous but um but no one really had a
spot for it I believe the men who were a
part of a club uh brought it back to
their Club Space for for everyone at the
club to enjoy that note a sincere
congratulations on the film and uh thank
you for uh giving me your time thank you
my friend thanks for your time